deepmind releases a system called
flamingo google releases a system called
lit and ai 21 labs releases a system
that's called miracle it's a fun week
welcome to ml news have fun
all right hey there my name is yannick
welcome to the channel this is already
part two of this week's news i've done
part one released it a few days ago so
if you haven't checked that out a lot
has happened in this week let's dive
into more of it deepmind releases a blog
post called tackling multiple tasks with
a single visual language model which
details a model that's called flamingo
so this model is essentially what gpt 3
was for language but for images and
language this means that it can take in
both images and language and multiple
images and multiple pieces of text and
then output a piece of text in response
to it it can also handle all of this in
a sort of conversational mode and it's
pretty powerful now one interesting
thing is that it builds upon pre-trained
and frozen models so as you can see
right here on the left the vision
encoder is completely frozen which is
indicated by the little snowflakey thing
the language model that everything feeds
into is completely frozen and the entire
training of the model is simply adapting
these in-between parts these adapters
that connect the two modalities together
that's pretty cool here you can see an
example the first image is a chinchilla
along with a description the second
image is a shiva along with a
description the third image is a
flamingo and then the model is supposed
to complete what this is and it bases
this upon the entire prompt which is
images and text this model can be used
in a multitude of ways it can do
classification by simply scoring answers
it can do image captioning it can do
question answering about images even
about video since you can take in
multiple images and those frames of a
video and it pushes the state of the art
in various image language tasks here you
can see another bunch of interactions so
what is in the picture it's a bowl of
soup with a monster face on it what's
the monster made of and it says it's
made of vegetables the operator says nah
probably not it's a fabric and the model
says it's wool which you know it's quite
a special image all right this is
yannick from the future we have some new
results out of flamingo now deepmind
seems to follow this similar strategy as
openai's which i'm going to guess they
observed and they learned that it works
namely that you give your employees and
a bunch of like very trusted first beta
users access to the model and then you
instruct all of them or you let them
tweet about it so it on social media it
looks like it's coming from many people
and not just from like one corporate
account makes it seem much more organic
but you know as long as this group is
very tightly controlled take all the
outputs with a grain of salt
nevertheless we do have some outputs
right here so i've seen this picture
going around and variations of it i
don't know if this is the only one but
they are all very similar in their
result andre carpati originally i
believe posted this photograph and and
essentially said this should be one of
or this could be one of the benchmark
tasks for visual models if a visual
model could explain why this picture is
funny that would be i guess
i don't know impressive and people have
been trying as i said to post these
conversations with flamingo which is
certainly impressive but you have to
lead flamingo to the point where it kind
of tells you why it's funny you can't
just ask why is this funny and it says
well there's a guy trying to read his
weight but then obama's foot on it so
it's heavier than the guy thinks and so
on but the guy doesn't know so you have
to sort of lead i mean you can go find
this picture for yourself not going to
read the whole thing but you have to
lead it to like what is he doing he's
looking at the scale where is obama's
foot position it's positioned on the
right side of the scale what happens as
a result the scale shows higher so you
you have to like carry the questions
along so i don't think that challenge
has been passed quite yet by flamingo
another cool thing that i've seen this
by alexa gordage the model is very
non-susceptible to some of the
let's say properties of visual models
especially visual models if you train
them on the classification task they
will often interpret this top picture
here as elephant because they focus on
textures where as i'm going to guess if
you train with more of a image language
focus that tends to focus more on object
dns inside of images so flamingo
correctly recognized what correctly it
recognizes this is a picture of a cat
which i'm going to guess most humans
would also see like this even though the
picture is clearly i guess nonsensical
if you want and then if it doesn't if
there's no shape in it it says this is a
picture of elephant's skin another cool
one is this one right here there's this
picture with the this giant cat in it
and flamingo says this is a model of a
city it looks like a tiny city with a
lot of people and cars which is correct
i don't know a human would maybe say
well it's a tiny city and there's
normal-sized cat in it but again if you
kind of lead the model to what you sort
of want to get out of it it gets it
ultimately so it says is there anything
unusual it says i see a cat in the photo
is there anything unusual about the cat
the cat is very big so ultimately you
get the answer you want again you have
to sort of get stuff out of the model
yeah it's not really touring test
passing yet i would say in this tasks at
least but it's getting there like
there's not too much missing i feel
until this is really at the level of
humans explaining these types of
pictures not agi just at this task it's
very impressive not quite there yet as
you often have to lead it but you know
getting there another thing also about
lewis which i found quite funny is this
one uploading a picture of i guess
himself with the drawn on beard the
model says this is a selfie of a man
with a beard now there's two
possibilities right here one is that the
model was actually fooled by the beard
and two is that the model realized that
lewis had put a lot of effort into that
beard but he just isn't very skilled at
drawing it doesn't want to hurt his
feelings so it's complementing his
drawing skills in this way we don't know
it could be much smarter than you
initially think so you know who knows
now back to yannick in the past now
there is a paper to go along with it
it's 66 pages long and very detailed and
very cool and probably deserves its own
video another highlight is that the
model builds upon the perceiver
architecture which means that as you can
see here for example the image part on
the left here goes into a perceiver
resampler model which is one of these
adapter model that they train during
training and then that is routed into
the main part via these learned latent
queries of the perceiver so a perceiver
in this way works a bit different than
something like gpt3 which just always
attends to the entire past the perceiver
has a latent stream of information that
it carries through and then tries to add
to that using attention into the things
that come in so into the pictures from
here on out and then it merges that into
the entire language model transformer so
here you can see one block of that
language model transformer it is
essentially as you know a language model
but it every now and then gets these
cross inputs from this gated cross
attention dense layer which is exactly
where that visual information comes in
from the perceiver resampler another
interesting thing here is the collection
of data they sampled 43 million web
pages for images and text and used as
far as i can tell visual analysis in
order to see which text goes with which
image which text comes before which text
comes after and so on and all of this is
essentially processed to one stream of
information that consists of images text
and pointers to how they connect safe to
say this paper is packed with
information and packed with cool ideas
and i think the possibilities of both
vision text models together but also the
combination of learned parts and then
frozen parts and how that all works how
we can reuse knowledge that we take from
single task models and then fuse them
together is very promising direction
which brings us into the next story
google research releases a paper on
locked image tuning abbreviated lit so
this is a model that combines the
advantages of fine tuning but also the
advantages of contrastive pre-training
now if you do contrastive training
usually you take two pieces of
information in these cases again an
image and a text and you try to align
their embeddings as much as possible
this results in representations in which
you can do similarity search and all
kinds of things over these inputs for
example the clip model can do zero shot
classification by simply taking an image
listing all the classes and then
evaluating the similarity of the
representations to each of the classes
on the other hand there is the method of
fine-tuning in which you take some sort
of model like a pre-trained imagenet
model and then transfer or fine-tune it
to your task locked image tuning
combines both of them so what it does is
it has a pre-trained image encoder and
then it only fine-tunes the text encoder
such that the pieces of text the
representations match with the
representations that the image encoder
gives now you might think that is a step
back namely something like clip tunes
both the image encoder and the text
encoder however what this paper finds is
that if you freeze the vision model then
you do get much better performance there
is something about the contrastive
training that almost loses a bit of
information that the pre-trained vision
encoder would contain otherwise
therefore simply fine-tuning the text
model helps a lot in retaining a lot of
that information there's also a little
bit of an online demo where you can try
out the tool so you can select one of
these images and then you can give it a
bunch of classes a bunch of labels and
then evaluate that model what's also
cool is that this demo runs fully in the
browser you only have access to the tiny
and small model because otherwise your
browser would catch fire i guess however
it's pretty cool that you can do this at
all
[Music]
ai21 labs releases jurassic x in a blog
post called crossing the neural symbolic
chasm with the mrkl system this is the
modular reasoning knowledge and language
system and is abbreviated miracle now
this here is both about a concept for a
new system these miracle systems as well
as a first implementation of it in the
form of jurassic x now previously ar21
has built a language model called
jurassic 1 which was similar to gpt3 and
now they're using that language model to
interact with non-neural systems so the
idea in miracle systems is that you
combine the language model together with
a bunch of what they call experts so
experts here are in form of for example
a weather api a currency converter
wikipedia api a calendar app some sort
of calculator stock databases anything
that you can query get inputs from or
send inputs to and get some sort of
results out of those notably these are
black boxes and for sure they're not
backpropable they're not differentiable
so the challenge is how do you make
these language models interact with
these experts the way jurassic x does it
is in form of these input adapters which
will analyze the input query which is in
natural language in this case which
green companies had the largest
increased share price in the last month
they will then go out and query all of
the available experts with the input
that they parse out of the language
merge all of this in a very discreet and
symbolic fashion into a calculator
experts that they also have access to
and at the end this goes back into a
language model which then gives you a
language answer this obviously is a more
tedious more manual more engineering
intensive effort than something like
gpt3 that simply gives you an answer out
of the box however when it comes to more
complicated stuff i believe that this
approach here might be promising so so
far if we want something like gpt3 to do
multi-step reasoning or anything like
this we can do it sort of by prompting
it very intelligently however it
currently has its limits you can clearly
see how this architecture would help a
lot with that however on the other hand
the challenge with this architecture is
how do you connect these black box
discrete parts with the neural parts and
probably promising approaches might lie
somewhere in the middle either by making
these black boxes more accessible to the
neural things like somehow combining
them with back backprop or maybe
combining something like the reasoning
prompt engineering from gpt3 with traces
of how people use these experts i don't
know how it's ultimately going to look
but it's pretty cool additionally having
these experts decouples what the
language model needs to do namely
language and parsing things out of
language with the abilities of the
experts for example calculating some
functions or looking up some data online
which is something that frozen language
models can't even do no matter how big
they are hey this is yannick from the
future i don't think i've made this
really clear in the original post that i
made about this but you can actually
enter your own queries here they have
three experts available one is the
calculator one is jurassic one the
language model and one is the titanic db
so a database of passengers of the
titanic so you can enter any question in
here how much is the fish
and
the fish costs 1.99 this is answered
directly by the jurassic one model now
let's let's try to make use of some of
these experts how many
passengers
over 30 years old
survived on the titanic
let's see if he gets it
okay select count survived from titan
i like i came up i did not test this
before this video
this this is quite impressive how many
meters
is the
capital
of tibet higher
than the capital of india
by how many meters okay well still the
jurassic language model answered this
one i was trying to get it to route to
the calculator but what i want to stress
is that you can input your own queries
right here and directly try the model
this is very cool and very different
from other models that you don't have
access to at all like dali or flamingo
and where the website you can only
select predefined queries so i wanted to
highlight that here yes they do have
predefined queries to give you an idea
however you can also definitely go and
just enter your own so try it out
[Music]
all right and now we're going into a
long list of helpful things and cool
things that i've just seen around
stalgan human is a ganner even multiple
gans that are trained on humans humans
and different clothing in different
positions and is pretty good i have to
say they have a nice website and a video
to go along with it if you want to know
how it works you can do things like
interpolation and every time i see
something like this i'm just amazed at
you know how far gans have come this has
nice applications for things like
fashion design or if you want to shop
something in an online store to see how
it would look on you or just kind of
editing your style and clothes and look
as you can see right here sleeves are
shortened and elongated skirts and pants
and tops are edited all kinds of fun
stuff there's a paper and a github repo
and the models are available to download
graphic is a data augmentation library
for pytorch geometric so this brings
data augmentation to graph neural
networks usually data augmentation
obviously very widely used in things
like vision however graph neural
networks are kind of a new thing and
this library provides some useful
augmentation tools for that especially
if you work with pytorch geometric give
this a try burton gptj6b is a spanish
fine-tuned version of gptj6b
if you want to generate text in espanol
check it out torchdistx is the
repository for experimental stuff in
torch distributed so this is where all
the stuff goes that is not yet quite
ready for pytorch distributed one cool
thing is the fake tensor now they
already have meta tensors and fake
tensors are quite similar but i didn't
know either so i thought it was cool
this is a tensor that looks like it's
allocated somewhere on a device and you
can work with it however it isn't so
when you want to access the data or do
anything with it it either fails or it
then needs to load the data at that time
this is especially useful in order to do
any sort of delayed execution of stuff
but you already want to build the
computation graph or in order to inspect
models that are just too large for you
to load them all at once so you kind of
load the graph in but not the way it's
not any of the data and you just look at
individual parts and you just load them
as needed very cool vector flow by
netflix is another neural network
library however this one is optimized
for sparse data and single machine
environments which is a good use case
it's not a very standard one so this
might actually be interesting for you to
do some new things on it i saw this blog
post from the iclear blog track the 37
implementation details of proximal
policy optimization and this is
obviously something that is well known
in the domain of reinforcement learning
namely that these algorithms are not
stable they require a lot and a lot and
a lot of tricks to get working and
that's why people usually regress to
taking standard implementations rather
than implementing it themselves don't
try to implement rl algorithms yourself
it is a pain and it is almost always
better to take a baseline even if you
want to invent something new start from
a baseline good implementation and then
work your way up from there this blog
post details 37 implementation details
for ppo so if you want to figure out
what kind of work goes into something
like stable baselines three maybe give
this blog post a read deepmind tweets
about the release of four new libraries
for the jax ecosystem i have to say jax
is looking better and better by the day
so there's mctx which does monte carlo
tree search in jacks there's kfac jax
which is a second order optimization
library there's dm aux which is a sound
and audio signal processing library and
there is tf2 jax which converts
tensorflow functions and graphs into
jacks mgpt is a 1.3 billion parameter
language model that has been trained on
over 60 languages and is available on
hogging face if you do anything in terms
of multilingual natural language
generation this might be a good starting
point clean lab is an open source
library that helps you find and correct
labeling mistakes in data if you work in
the real world and you have messy data
and you suspect labeling errors are a
big problem which they probably are
maybe give clean lab a shot they assist
you in fixing mistakes and sometimes
they even do it automatically shout out
to the efficient deep learning book this
book is in a draft stage and you can
already look at the first four chapters
of it from the table of contents you can
see that it deals with stuff like
compression techniques more efficient
learning techniques and in the later
stages it takes some deep dives into
specific platforms for example
tensorflow or into specific models here
for example bert or mobilenet or
efficientnet so if you want to be not
just a user but a knower maybe this book
is for you the mini hack level editor is
a level editor for mini hack if you use
mini hack in any sort of experimentation
which i could be fun it looks like fun
certainly this level editor will help
you make some nice test cases for your
agent at inference time i mean you could
do it for training time but how many are
you gonna make in any case you can
select width and height then you can
place the walls and you can place the
lava how about some lava here oh yeah
mujen is a playground for video audio
text multimodal understanding and
generation so this is a data set of
gameplay of an open source game so
here's how that looks
so what you saw is a piece of gameplay
and then they also always showed you the
pixel segmentation map so this is video
segments from a bot playing this game
and the idea is that there are multiple
modalities combined so there's always
the sound there is the picture that you
get and there is this pixel-wise
segmentation map so this is intended for
you to build models that understand
what's happening by considering multiple
input streams at once it's very cool
they have 375 000 of these video clips
and along the clips they also have
textual descriptions of what's happening
in them amazon releases the massive data
set this is a big data set as the name
says and it is a 51 language data set
containing utterances in the respective
languages along with code to get started
so if you're doing very multilingual
natural language understanding this
might be a good data set openfx is an
open source 3d face animation system so
the goal here is to have a system that
simulates realistic facial expression
this is probably one of the hardest
tasks you can do because we humans are
excellent at recognizing when a facial
expression is not realistic but the
simulator makes a very good impression
and could be the basis of many ml inputs
or output pipelines
[Applause]
ah see it doesn't like smile with your
eyes that's what they always say you're
not you're not smart you're not smiling
with your eyes ah wait this could be the
thumbnail
avalanche is an end-to-end library for
continual learning based on pytorch so
this is a library that seeks to just
make continual learning a whole lot
easier for you i can imagine i've never
done anything in continued learning but
i can imagine that it's quite hard
because many components need to come
together this stuff goes on for a long
time even infinite time right you have
to keep track of stuff keep track of
checkpoints be able to roll back have
replay buffers evaluate at regular
intervals yada yada so if there is a
library that handles a lot of that in
one very cool
[Music]
and the last thing this ai does not
exist.com will generate you descriptions
and small usage code snippets of ai
projects that do not exist so what you
can do is you can click next here for
example this is the hacker news reply
guy ai which is a bot for the hacker
news comment section here you get a
little bit of a code snippet on how that
works if you press next then you'll get
the next ai but you can also enter your
own name so let's try that how about
yeah
you only
poop
once
this is a little bit of play on yolo
let's see what comes out pun intended
yopo is a neural network that learns to
predict if an image of a dog will result
in a poop or not it was developed by a
team at the university of bonn and the
university of amsterdam great work
university of pond university of
amsterdam this is world changing you can
even see here the snippet says i should
load the image dog
jpeg
excellent excellent it's apparently
convnet so i'm quite relieved all right
that was already it for ml news this
week thank you so much for being here if
you have news tips don't hesitate to
come by our discord or if you just want
to hang out i mean that's cool too in
any case i'll see you next week and stay
hydrated bye
[Music]